good day everybody today we have an
extra special guest Brandon Laatsch we
went out into our Hall we walked down
that hall we went next door to his
studio which is right next to ours and
we said hey Brandon come on over here we
want to talk to you a little bit about
VR we want to talk about gaming we want
to talk about your time on YouTube and
your transition off of the Freddy W
Channel let's also talk about digital
humans and a lot of other cool features
too concepts and much much more get
ready for an awesome interesting
engaging conversation with one of our
long time hometown friends Brandon watch
here we go bringing bandit on to the
show Brandon jr. we're gonna we're gonna
interview bandit and talk about dogs dog
life pet grooming biscuits she lives a
really good one that's for sure she's
like only child status for a longer than
she should be yeah well we've been where
we're bringe we're yeah I can't even
talk right now here
right now the podcast starts 3 2 1
action alright there we go that's the
beginning the podcast I told you guys in
here 9:30 so yeah early for us I've
never had you want to do something this
early before I know I had a double take
when Jake was like 9:30 I'm like night
he's gonna be here I've been trying to
just keep like focused on the work as
much as I can so I try to keep
everything out of that block of time now
so how long has that been going on
you've been cranking over there for a
long time now uh I've been yeah I've I
mean I've been working on this current
project probably two years now I guess
some of it was simultaneous with duck
season and then it's been it's been
going on beyond that so now the entire
team's all hands on deck on the same
project and then we've been crunching
for the last couple months probably and
I don't know like 12 hours a day or so
it's called bone works called bone works
and it's and it's not technically a game
or is it a game oh it's a game it's a
narrative it's a narrative game okay
we called bone works it's gonna be
called bone work really yep
cuz I thought that was the name of like
the engine or like the system or
something for some reason if I went into
the full pay
it would make it would make sense yeah
but yeah it is it is both the engine the
system a fictional engine and system as
well as the title of the first game
which is a narrative that's super cool
VR thing I don't really meta with this
like oh yeah it's all it's all like
layered and they all play off of each
other and there's always I mean you
figure like you look at how like like a
zeldo series goes and you have the tired
like messy timeline which is basically
just a playground where we can always
insert another title here there and so
we figured like all of our games we have
to at least have some like connective
tissue at some level but it's vague
enough that anything goes right and so
you have like some way that you can
always tie things together so that
people can eventually make the big
charts of like connecting these
timelines together and where the
universe divided and merged and you know
as people get into that stuff so you
went from a a top-ten YouTube channel to
virtual reality video game development
is that not the usual path yeah I
thought you had to become a video game
tester first get into video games yeah
the QA process we don't know it's so
weak you eat a lot of titles oh yeah
really access that it's like man maybe
we can do better
yeah I was talking to uh Anthony from
Smosh mm-hmm at a VidCon and I was I was
talking about games and it kind of
dawned on me that it that it wasn't that
common of a path because I was like he's
like well what do you have to it I'm
like I'm doing this stuff you know and
talking about all the different games
and and titles and like things we want
to do with VR and looking at us a medium
that's similar to YouTube was and we
found it in 2010 that's like a nascent
medium we can kind of formulate and try
to push in whatever direction we wanted
to go and he kind of had this like blank
look who's like dang I'm making I'm
making some videos that I'm excited
about but but it's like normally people
kind of do more like they stay in their
field and I guess to me it never really
felt like that much of different field
because coming from the visual effects
side of things it's just more it's just
another gray dark gray program and the
same sort of you know it's polygons and
vertices and move them around and then
beyond that you're trying to create a
entertaining piece of content you're
trying to make something for people to
play and enjoy and you know there's no
Turbots been playing and watching it in
the days
a different way of experiencing
something so both storytelling wives as
well as creatively it seems like it's
not in my mind at least it doesn't feel
like that big of a journey
yeah well it's it also kind of kind of I
guess it shows that you know I hate to
use that word creator but you know one
of the you're one of those creators who
is you know is you know more on the I
guess backend you know able to actually
construct the piece from both a
conceptual and a technical standpoint
whereas you know you see a lot of people
who are or you know personality focused
where it's like their their personality
is what they bring to the table rather
than the actual like infrastructure of
creating the content as well and so you
know I for me I'm like oh yeah that
makes sense because of how technically
minded you know I guess you guys were
with the Freddy W Channel makes total
sense I mean it is it really is that it
is the same stuff except there's just a
little more code now how do you do a lot
of coding do a lot of coding now yeah so
I originally I started coding for my
ti-83 high like everybody did was like
you get the drug wars based game right
and you start changing first you change
the police officer's name and you find
some strings he added oh and then you're
like wow if I could you know make this
rain of event and you start dabbling and
and so I coated in junior high for a few
years and then stepped away from it for
for a couple decades mm-hmm and then
came around to it again about about two
years ago hmm I started doing in a
background while people were you know we
had people working on duck season and I
was I was contributing a little bit on
the code side of that but not
tremendously I was made more of like
working out sort of like passion
projects and uh like experimentation
stuff and lo and behold that all turned
into the decor the bone works
engine now that was the sort of like
early stuff from that and now we're all
hands on deck developing then getting it
to market mm-hmm so it's a wide virtual
reality why not like go traditional 2d
passengers so there's there's a bit of a
chip on my shoulder from that and that
this is a bit of a tangent from that but
uh essentially there's I never realized
that there's just community of like
futurists right hmm that kind of jump
from one thing to the next and when we
came into YouTube in 2010 that was in
that sort of like futurist mindset where
people you know some creators are
looking at it it's like oh this is the
next big thing I want to do this and
then a lot of those people jump ship to
the next platform the next thing you
know just because it's the next latest
greatest thing mm-hmm and we skipped
some in there and then we picked up
virtual reality and there's the same
thing at the time it's the only this big
futurist thing and now you have like ARS
coming along and everyone's like oh why
are you gonna switch over to a arts like
no we pick and choose the mediums
because we want to create something in
that and it turns out that I thought
there was a large like-minded community
but it turns out there's like there's a
there's a handful that are really
passionate about it but then there's a
lot of people that are actually they're
more passionate about what's the next
thing than they are about actually
developing something yeah so we chose VR
because it had the same spark it had the
same feel as YouTube did to me and that
in that YouTube was an opportunity to
revolutionize the way that we got
content to the viewer and that you could
bypass the studio system could bypass
all the gatekeepers and suddenly just
make things and on the merit of your own
creation obviously within the
constraints of that medium you'd be sort
of judged by your by your peers with and
rewarded with views and and people
coming back and tuning into what you're
doing and VR differently but let's but
similarly has this aspect of it with
gaming where there's only been in my
mind one other time where gaming's god
had an opportunity completely
revolutionized and that was when going
from 2d to 3d so so you had this time
around like the late late 90s where
there's like you know you know John
Carmack was in there and you had a
handful of people in there that were on
the engineering side and then else on
the creative side trying to turn over
the entire thing and then for 20 years
the it largely sat dormant and just sort
of those same mechanics you look at like
half-life 2 pretty much established the
the formula for the first-person game as
we know at first person shooter at least
right where you have some physics
objects in there and you have some guns
you have some enemies and you go through
some levels that tells you a story and
we've largely just taken that and made
it more open world since then but it's
pretty much the same mechanics yeah that
were established then and in a way I
mean half-life 2 at the time seemed very
open world
I'd even argue the first half-life
because like that that really I feel
like still had that same same same
feeling you could probably turn the
clock back even more but yeah
and I don't have any like ideas for 2d
of a 3d gaming on a 2d monitor that
suddenly I think the name of that game
is now trying to combine what you've
seen and tell a new story and make
something new in that but it's it's a
evolving you know slowly evolving what's
there worse whereas VR is this
opportunity to kind of completely turn
over the mechanics and come up with new
core systems and yeah that's I think I
think I thrive in that environment much
better than then trying to you know
trying to try to pick you know to a few
mechanics in there to tighten up or try
to do in a slightly different way mmm I
get rewards small teams they can move
fast and and make something new yeah
well especially because you know the
hardware's coming out so so frequently
and I feel like there's like you're the
updates really at least you know and
yeah if you're anything more than like a
small team you can't move that fast
so if you consider like VR next gen it
doesn't seem like it's very really
taking off very fast right now you know
there's a lot of talk about how many
headsets will be out there and I'm a
huge VR fan pretty much all my gaming
takes place either NPR on the switch
which is also a bit of a departure from
the traditional platform - a little bit
of an extent and I pretty much only play
escape from tarkov on the PC yeah so
what is a what is holding the air back
from taking off quickly right now why is
it being adopted so slowly I think so I
think a lot of people would tell you
that the the hardware's not there yet
and I completely disagree with that
I think the hardware is is good enough
and the the next generation of
hardware's come out we're pretty much
I'm like a yearly you know there'll be a
new bump up in the resolution of
headsets
every two years one year or so and we're
due for that next generation will bump
next year and it'll keep you know
getting better with slightly higher
fidelity but the system is the headsets
that are currently out right now at the
oculus and the vive primarily are going
to be the cheap you know that the
affordable option that people are able
to get in by for bumming around you know
$300 but hopefully by next year 250 $200
so essentially that is what the bulk of
our users going forward you know a year
from now we're still going to be using
so the hardware has to be good enough
already
and I think it is I think the issue is
more the software's not good enough yet
I don't think the content is good enough
and that's the problem that we're trying
to fix and I hope that we've I think
we've cracked it right now I think we
we've been quiet for a very long time
and what we're working on and we've kind
of taken a step back and rebuilt
everything that we were doing and tried
to kind of go back to what the community
was saying cuz we heard from the
mainstream a lot that essentially that
games they're happy with the way games
are and they like the idea of VR and
they warmed up to it they got away from
the whole like oh this is just the next
connect there's something like that and
they started to get into the mode of
like we like VR but we're willing to
wait until you make games that are the
type of games we want to play and by
that they mean they don't want to lose
in either feature set that they're used
to in a in a traditional game because
when they think of VR they think of oh
I'm gonna be you know take right at
redemption to or something like that
like right at redemption 3 could be in
VR but they wouldn't want to lose any of
the mechanics all right they still want
to ride a horse they still want to run
around they want to shoot guns probably
play in first-person right yes it is a
third-person and they want to they want
to be whatever the protagonists if it's
John Marston or whoever they're playing
ass and they want to and they want to
live in that world they wanna be
immersed in that world and so far VR
developers have told them those things
are very very hard to do and may not be
possible to do without a getting you
motion sick and be there are some issues
with like you're moving one to one in
the world but your character is not
moving one to one with that and so how
do we rectify that in a way that feels
satisfying yeah or maybe Vic the special
edition like horse that you have to buy
it's like horse dummy you buy and put in
your living room and you sit on it it's
like a rocking horse that simulates the
horse riding and it's like you need all
these accessories all these things and
make something it works and so we kind
of took a step back on the last one and
thought and took another look at like is
this possible and the conclusion we came
to is that it all suddenly seemed
possible it's just a tremendous amount
of work and a tremendous amount of math
to get it to work and so we started
chipping away at that and what we've
come to now we when we first showed a
video on we showed a video on node know
six months ago it's called quite a bit
since then but there's a glimpse of it
so there's a public glimpse of it right
now and the first thing we wanted to do
that I was working on is I wanted to
have
physically controlled hands I wanted
your hands to be not your hands of this
world but your hands of the games world
so so what do you be by physically
controlled I mean that the hands that
you see in the game are completely being
driven by by Newtonian physics that
rather than just saying hey this frame
my hand moved here so I'm just gonna
move that the position of that hand
object they're just one to one that's
obviously the quickest and easiest way
to do it instead we're saying oh I moved
by 10 centimeters and my hand weighs 2
kilograms so I need to add 20 Newton's
of force this in this direction on this
frame to move it there and essentially
it's almost like the way a drone flies
itself it's got a PID controller which
is guiding it through the sky to try to
maintain its position reacting to forces
so if you push on it I didn't know you
were gonna push on it but now it knows
oh I'm off kilter so I need more forces
so your hands are doing that and that
took a lot to to get it to be responsive
and physical and then in the same muscle
space of the character so what does that
do what does that actually do at the end
of the day what that does is it's it's a
fundamental transformation of what we're
thinking of for the VR experience and
that instead of taking you as a person
into a game you are puppeteering your
your puppeteering and avatar essentially
you're playing as a character which is
much more like read at redemption - and
any other game you look at where you're
playing as that as a character right
mm-hmm and within that world you have
the same problems and the limitations
and abilities and strengths of that of
that character and on a practical side
what that means is we can we can sort of
divorce the hands from the player's
hands and because we're then the next
phase of it after we have the physics
hands drawing an entire body that's
layered on top so you can see it it
allows us to get away with more where if
I if I grab a heavy object and lift it
up really quickly my hand can can be
slightly behind because it's holding a
heavy object or if I grab something that
weighs you know hundreds of pounds and
try to lift my hands this won't go up or
my hands will pop off because I can't
pick that thing up and suddenly get this
like this look that feels right for the
world and it took us a long time out to
kind of take you know I mean you guys
had a chance to to play some of it and
you guys should come by and play the the
latest demo when
whenever you're ready but essentially
we've gone into a way that it feels
it doesn't feel sluggish or like
dreamlike like things aren't working
they feel they feel right and they sort
of rewards you for what for for playing
as if you're in that world it's
interesting that's true that's really
cool I haven't because I actually
haven't played the demo got to play but
it sounds it sounds like no no but it
sounds like what it's doing though on a
conceptual level is when you when you
mentioned the puppeteering it's it's the
concept of like yeah it's it's not you
in this world it's this character and so
honestly it's like it's like a separate
level of immersion like it's not it's
not like immersive in a first-person
sense but like you know it's it's it's a
different type of connection into this
game world which I find really
fascinating here's the interesting thing
is it's everybody as far as I know like
our greatest ally is is the players the
players mind yeah in that everybody has
the ability to have lucid dreams to
dream and to sort of imagine like that's
sort of what makes us human we don't
know if bandit can do that you know I
don't think she can imagine what I'm
seeing I almost had a lucid dream last
night not to go on too big of a tangent
but so we have this innate like
subconscious ability to do this and so
in a way with VR if we can get close
enough to that the player already has
the ability in their mind to sort of let
themself get lost in this world and get
immersed and they want to and almost
like hypnotism right where it's it's not
gonna work if you're sitting there and
you're just saying like I'm just gonna
make this person look dumb I don't want
to be hypnotized it's like whoa
hypnotism really works when the person
is like it'd be more fun if I just go
along with it and before they know
they're just kind of going along with it
and they're going with it more and they
get lost in it and somebody's over there
like oh wow I don't really I'd never
felt like I was out of control yet I'm
just kind of on this this really fun
thing wasn't these fun suggestions from
from the hypnotist and it was a great
time why would I not want to do that
much like a dream mm-hmm do you think
people have been saying like the you
know not having a movement be one-to-one
with your in-game character that's a bad
thing can't do that
it ruins your immersion when your hand
in real life is one in one spot in your
hand and the game is in another spot are
they wrong I think I think they're wrong
and I think we we won that one and the
key with that is it so beyond once you
have those things working the nice thing
is that the 2d presentation of that
content once you film it and put it out
there
is much more palatable to the mainstream
user when people when you show that to
people they're like that is the VR that
I thought we were gonna get two years
ago that's what I was hoping for and
there's nothing really inherently about
it that we couldn't have coded two years
ago we just didn't know how and
apparently nobody else did either
because they didn't they didn't make it
yet and there's and it's just big eNOS
you know I mean we've been working in
space for probably about four years now
it's takings about four years to be able
to code and get it all together working
and we're just about getting ready to
premiere it and show to the world yeah
there are all those like little rules
that were suddenly invented when you
started with VR like oh you can't move
lis turn outside the players control it
makes you sick if you move outside the
players control that also makes you sick
but and maybe it doesn't actually if you
do it for a little while and then you
know and like there's always rules that
people can't just took for granted and
now I think I'm glad we're seeing people
go like wait wait those weren't rules we
were just we're all fresh on the boat
like sailors yeah I'm getting seasick
but now we're okay and we can you never
hear any like stories of like you know
back in the eighteen hundreds like some
people just just threw up on those sit
on those boats you know like you know
one guy I like kilometers ship like he
just couldn't go because he just
couldn't stop getting sick you know
months went by still throwing up every
day you know it's like you don't really
hear that like everybody's like we can't
pan the camera else they're gonna throw
up so we keep it locked off they started
like pushing it in turns out you can
actually go all the way to Bourne
Identity that's funny yeah so I had a
dream last night
sorry I'm just gonna finish up this
tangent so I dreamt I woke up and I was
like man that was a crazy dream was so
vivid I Mel like I was like I remember
my dream taking my phone and recording
it and I looked at my phone I'm like
holy crap if a video file on my phone I
actually have a recording for my dream
on my phone this is so weird like I have
I can show people what happened how did
I manage to get this on my phone and
like that part was very normal like I
was just sitting in my bed in the
morning like looking at my phone and
there's a video recording from my dream
on my phone that had recorded in my
dream and I was like this is like really
Ellucian airy like nobody's ever seen
anything like this and then i woke up
again and i was like oh lizard dreams
were right at the rule is at the moment
of lucidity when you realize that it's a
dream and that you can't have control is
that I I blast off flying straight up in
the air and the best as I can no matter
what somebody right and then I'm
dreaming I was trying to get as high as
I could right uh-huh
at one point I got off the space and
then I like I died and I couldn't I
couldn't breathe and then the next time
I when I realize I blast off I'm like
it's a dream no need for air I could I
went all the way to the moon damn call
of course and then uh and then it
happened again manage I managed to fly
all the way up to to Mars an automatic I
planted a flag oh really oh as far as I
know there's a flag on Mars that if I
can ever beat that that's like the rule
is how far can you go that's amazing no
persistent Flags new dreams or is it I
don't know I've never gotten to the flag
yet still be there now it's totally be
there man so all this awesome gaming and
VR stuff has brought you up to valve a
whole bunch I know you've been traveling
up to Washington so it's like there
things are things getting big getting
official with those guys cuz I'd imagine
you have a lot of fans up there we've uh
we've had a great relationship with with
Val furrow for a while now I think we
originally went to so dating back to
2011 actually with with Freddie we made
a video in 2011 I think was 2011 yeah
with a three where we composited a like
a valve and like you know like hl3 logo
like above a booth in a corner we're
like weird nobody's nobody's noticing
this and then we walked and we like
really really feel her stuff walking out
of this random door like that was the
real deal you know and and so we didn't
we didn't think much of it but then we
a few months later Friday of like
talking he's like he's a so we might be
going to valve apparently a bunch of
foreign media latched onto that and was
reaching out to them for PR statements
of like so what about what was this
booth at e3 makeup
they got pointed to our videos and so we
ended up going up there and it was right
after the launch of of portal 2 which is
an interesting moment in valve history
because that's the that's like the last
time that they put out a proper
single-player game right mmm and so it
was kind of a turning point for what
they were doing and we went up there and
talked with them just kind of it's kind
of one of those I mean you guys have
taken those meetings where it's like you
talked about YouTube and it's like so
what is this YouTube thing yeah but we
were we were talking to Gabe about it
and it was it was probably the most
intelligent version of that meeting I've
ever had and that and that
he asked the fewest questions and each
question was ten questions down the line
where it's like he was filling in the
gaps of like what was that so it was
really refreshing to see somebody get it
and click and then we talked about the
steam platform and how that's kind of an
interesting is since then like the steam
platform has become more YouTube like
right where there's more they're trying
to make it more open to more things
going on there yeah and then let
algorithms curate you know like what
gets seen by different things less hand
curation more of that and so so that was
the original time we went up there and
met and then and then years later once
we start getting the VR we quickly end
up going up to up to valve to sort of
demo our stuff and talk about the
headsets and this is actually pre HTC
vive that was when they had their
prototypes and they're working on track
controllers and they they ended up
showing us a early prototype of track
controllers mm-hm and we looked at those
witnesses odd this is with Alex now by
the way this was this is post post
Friday W and and so once we were up
there they showed us these track
controllers they showed us a headset
they didn't have them working together
yet you could have like one or the other
yeah and they're like but there I put
wink wink they called the Honeywell at
the time which we googled when we found
a Honeywell was was a brand that was
making laser trackers hmm turned into uh
which was basically an early version the
lighthouse system which I think what the
time was very much the size of these
lights and at that time we told them
like if you got
I can put these you know these control
you know controllers plus a headset in a
box and ship into consumers will have a
game on launch day and they kind of
laughing their echo we won't have
anything till 2018 mm-hmm then a few
months later the the vive ended up
getting announced and they and so we
called them up and they're like they're
like yep they're like we're good on our
promise if you guys are good on your
promise and they're like yeah so they
sent us some dev kits and that's what
led to hover Junkers nice and then uh
France from there on a couple times a
year
we'll end up going up there and kind of
trading ideas seeing what each other are
working on talk about the VR space and
where we're taking it and we just most
recently came back from a trip where we
uh we showed them showed them the latest
state of bone works and talking about
that and so we're just continuing to
march on in terms of what we're what
we're making and trying to get VR to to
a state where it can launch on to the
the general public and mass now Valve's
not really known for making too many
games anymore these days and obviously
seems a huge focus of their business and
I think you and I have theorized that
this a little bit due to like the
structure of the company is such that
there's not really like a boss per se
people just kind of work on what they
want to work on I believe it's like you
need to show results in a certain you
know manner that you like what you're
making is productive and it's obviously
easiest to do that if you Center it
around and steam and you know that
aspect of things or you know updating
upgrading counter-strike or dota and
things like that would you say that the
addition of VR has helped inspire people
at valve to get back into things other
than steam and like help you know I
think so I think it's a it's a it's a
breath of fresh air and also I think
about a year and a half ago or so you
saw a Turin where they kind of
consciously made a decision as a company
because like you said there's no there's
no structure where it's like there's no
one boss that's let's think this is what
we're doing now guys like get it done
but they're they're starting to get back
to you're seeing sort of the results of
it happening right now where artifact
finally launched and then the the update
to counter-strike with the these sort of
battlegrounds mode came into there and
so you're student starting to see things
come off are they acquired a the
Camposanto team about I think a year ago
what's Campo Santo they made a game
called fire watch oh right right and
they're making a this game called in the
valley of the gods which is now oh no a
valve game and so essentially that's you
know that's presumably still being
worked on up there and and coming out so
you're seeing the sort of this conscious
turn back towards towards making you
know single-player content and well and
and multiplayer content as well but
you're seeing more games start to ship
and I think I don't know something I
kind of observed with both both like
Blizzard and and valve that it seems
like the the the sort of the the
maintenance of the platform and the
weight of maintaining a platform the
merits of that sort of outweighed and
not just financially but also just in
terms of numbers on the platform
outweighed the value of making
single-player experiences for a while
mmm-hmm but I don't know about Blizzard
but but it seems like within valve you
definitely see this shift back towards
uh
like there is this sort of intangible
value to single-player content that it
builds IP better than anything else and
it builds a sort of like goodwill in
good faith with the community and that
people really remember those games
fondly like it seems like it's easier to
make a single-player game like a breath
of the wild that people look back ten
years oh I didn't go ding that's really
that's really cool than it is to be that
was a player game kind of way like they
a sort of time capsule better right you
can still go back and play Final Fantasy
seven just like the day it came out
pretty much but you can't go back and
play an online match of a Halo to you
right now anymore right yeah
unfortunately unless here the Master
Chief collection yeah fix that well you
know I think you could also look at
multiplayer gaming um kind of through
the lens of like YouTube I guess in the
sense that like if you look at how
YouTube democratizes slash
revolutionizes like video content you
know it's but it's it's also ad
supported so it's not like people are
paying for a product and then you look
at multiplayer gaming versus single
player gaming and you've obviously over
the last few years going towards like
free-to-play models it becomes almost ad
base again you know and so I think it's
you know gaming is that space unlike you
know film I paying for a movie ticket
but I think I think it's the thing where
it's like people like you get value true
value out of a single player like gaming
experience
versus a multiplayer one you know like
it's it's the it's like you know you put
your $60 down for a product and you
actually feel it when it's a
single-player title because it's like
here is actual content that people have
worked on and built versus a multiplayer
game or is like you know oh
hopefully it's fun to play with that
friends hopefully that you have friends
and everyone place nice good luck you
know they'd be back off you know the
community likes to latch on to like for
both blizzard and valve and any of these
and you know epic etc where they they
prioritize these big multiplayer games
because like you look at the revenue you
know Riot Games you look at the revenue
that comes in from a from a from a
mobile or something like that with all
the cosmetics and it's like that's just
bringing in billions of dollars right
yeah and while that's true it's it's
actually in the case of a platform
holder it's not the only it's not the
only incentive and the other incentive
is one that's much less you can't paint
it it's like this insidious thing by the
community as well but these these
multiplayer games bring in bring in the
users so if you're maintaining a
platform and you're trying to make a
good platform ecosystem for your for
your other developers and other users
and other people you look at like dota
brings in you know a millions of people
per of the concurrence I say this 10
million concurrent's on Steam at any
given time you know a couple million are
being brought in by those big those big
multiplayer games and you figure those
eyeballs are trickling over throughout
the rest of store and doing that whereas
you look at a single-player game like
portal 2 you know eight years on the
line there's not a whole lot of
concurrence in portal 2 right now right
so that's not really bringing new
bringing people or keeping people coming
back every day so you need these like
tentpole multiplayer things that have
ongoing which which both generate
revenue but also generate viewers so you
see platform holders really want to have
those things existing for a couple
different reasons and I think one you
could frame/s you know a big bad
corporation and the other you could
frame is like hey that's actually really
in the interest of the development
community as a whole
mm-hmm I mean I feel like if Wright
really wanted to smarten up to they
could release their own I mean it's
basically a platform at that point like
steam you know yes they only have one
game yeah imagine how many games riots
canceled at this point
I don't think I don't think your ID has
launched any more games
I think there's I think they I think
they've gotten they fell into the trap
of we don't want to put it out unless
it's like has a chance to be another
league that's a bad trap and that's a
bad trip good luck trying to make
another league and then every year that
goes pass every time you cancel one it's
like puts more weight on the next one
where it's like in hindsight it's like
man we should just been shipping things
right yeah I monkey off our back yeah no
somehow Blizzard managed to get that
monkey off their back with overwatch and
hearthstone - for their sure yeah so um
I have a question yeah hit it you go
yeah Blizzard and they make some how
they make popular games frequently not
all you know not every six months but
around once every two years so they seem
to drop a new game then you have riot
and they haven't been able to make a
game since League of Legends that's been
popular mm-hmm
now popularity and understanding
popularity has been like a cornerstone
of your approach to business and media I
mean if you look back to when you were
running the Freddy W channel with Freddy
understanding popularity and not only
like what's popular but how to make it
fresh and now make it original and make
people talk about it
like that's that's like what you guys
launched that channel on and what you
used that skill you use to build it up
to be I think you hit number five or
number four sand like that for a
moment.we at five but mission I it
depends if you count machinima okay they
put it like fifteen thousand videos
right it was kind of different the ones
that were in our league we're like you
know we're all right hey gun yeah
nigahiga smosh and raywilliamjohnson man
and then we were we were right there
yeah so you've you've had this thought
process about you know you understand
how to make something popular that
people want but you're not necessarily
overly derivative about it like you're
not going out there and making like a
fortnight clone you know you're working
out how to do a twist how to bring
something fresh to the table and I'm
curious like what is that thought
process like how do you come to these
ideas like where's your head at to
create these these
our ideas whether it's a short-film idea
or a video game idea
I think the before even that I think the
firt the cornerstone of it is you have
to have a highly iterative process and
that and your iterations have to have a
quick turnaround right in that you see a
lot of like like the sort of the
battlegrounds way of right now you're
seeing a lot of people two years removed
release their battlegrounds clones and
they didn't pull the trigger
on their iteration on their on their
versions of them soon enough they waited
they waited for pub G to make you know
half a billion dollars then they're like
oh that's a good idea
let's make one and then 18 months later
they hit market and everyone's like them
the wave you know that's already
crashing on the beach right it's already
it's already over and and then you look
back and you see you know ARMA 3 with
the better rail and you see the
minecraft mod of battle royale and you
see the culling with its like early sort
of indie version of battle royale and
it's like why didn't you guys pull the
trigger back then why didn't you start
making your iterations of it you know
earlier and the ones that did they're
the ones that got rewarded if you wait
until it reaches that level success that
you've waited too long and that's and
that's just like cloning you know
somebody else's concept or doing that
with the with both the Freddy W Channel
and now with game development we tried
to always have a very quick turnaround
in that most ideas you know there was an
idea book that was always growing and
growing because we'd write down anything
that we had that was addition to it most
of the ideas were things that we came up
with that week mmm and I think you see
in TV you see South Park has a very
similar process where they're pretty
much making that new episode those two
weeks before it comes out and they're
putting it out and because they have a
faster response time than everybody else
you can get out ahead of all those waves
before they crash so that's that's just
in sort of riffing on pop culture and
then beyond the pop culture side of it
by having that those iterations by
getting more repetitions and then then
your peers I think you're it's like
you're exercising like a mental like a
mental muscle that that most people will
never take the time to develop or never
have the opportunity to develop because
once you I da ting is a is a skill just
like just like anything else and there's
you obviously you're born with a certain
amount of natural you know aptitude and
then you're raised in a Paranal
environment which either Foster's that
have to do door washes it you know and
then you finally get to the point where
you spread your wings and your
your individual person and you've either
worked on it a lot or you haven't and
it's never too late even if you haven't
had those things but it's you're gonna
have to get those reps and beyond your
natural aptitude it's like uh it's like
a D&D character right you have your
natural role in your skill and then you
can you can keep grinding it out or you
can neglect it and let it sit and so
getting ourselves in that situation
where we were I always say like so we
grew up and we all grew up together in
Minnesota yeah I like referring to
Minnesota especially now where in game
development as a sandbox state and it
get a lot of space there was very little
threat from the law and there was a lot
of physics objects around you could
combine and mold and then the other way
and there wasn't a whole lot of like
prescribing like activities that were
just like already made we're sort of at
the beginning that wave where it's like
our parents are like man we didn't have
you know VA a soccer when we were
growing up we're gonna enroll you and
this thing in this thing and it's like
no no I want to I want to quit all those
things and instead just like just have
free time right like after school come
home and it's just like just up just a
just a boy in the wilderness yeah like
I'm this I'm gonna I'm gonna try cut
this tree down with a shotgun you know
and there's gonna shoot it 20 times like
it didn't fall over now I know my skills
yeah I think we do we shoot the tree the
shotguns we did you actually cut down a
tree at my dad's house in the shotgun
Lexie yeah what uh how far away do you
have to be from a shotgun blast it's not
gonna hurt it will only go through one
side of the soda can so therefore if I
stand 200 yards it probably won't go
through my skin you're right it won't
[Laughter]
tell me this story Oh like we had this
neighbor this the slingers that always
was like swingers last names wingers and
we'd go over to their backyard and it
was always like we'd set up um how's
Luke Frederick myself and the slinger
boys and we'd have a bunch of shotguns
and rifles and the set of targets and
and their dad would always um even
though they weren't
impoverished he'd always like bring home
like boxes
fruit from the like the food stamps type
of thing which she probably shouldn't
been knows for the poor people but he
was bringing him home cuz he's like this
is good fruit we're gonna eat this it
was always going bad and so we'd always
just like go and shoot that fruit and
after a while shooting fruit you know
you get you get a little bored and we
wanted to try testing to see if if you
know like what what range is a shotgun
lose effectivity and what range is it
less powerful than like a BB gun as far
as getting shot because we'd have a BB
gun fights with each other mm-hmm and so
we after a series of tests we progressed
to the point of determining that about
150 yards it was only going through one
side of a soda cans or like was
comfortably a little further away and
then and then I believe it was guys Adam
singer that went out there he lost the
you know he lost the rock-paper-scissors
tournament and this is really
nerve-racking even though to do all the
tests when it's like oh and it's like I
think it was Luke Frederic that was
holding the gun and he's holding it and
nothing bad happened we fired the gun
yeah that means like a couple beams
around his Maggie to the spread was
pretty far at that point but he had like
a few little red marks and he was good
to go see like a jacket on if you're
live he was wearing like a sweatshirt
like I said he like turned away all
right you move back you know back to it
[Laughter]
I can only hope that like I can raise my
son like well enough to trust him to
literally play with guns safely on one
hand yeah you guys learned a lot about
guns and you did your proper experiments
in your iteration to make sure it was
safe yep do you do you test I think I
think a lot of like my early like life
Matt mantra was that everybody always
wants to say like don't do that you'll
die mmm and they're like the worst case
scenario is always you die and that's a
very lazy worst-case scenario because
worst case scenario is rarely just so
simple as you die you know it's like
what is the actual worst-case scenario
and so trying to do a very realistic
like analysis of what's the actual risk
here was the best case scenario is a
worst case scenario and instead of
thinking best-case scenario we could
become billionaires and worst case
scenario we die neither those things
usually ever happen you know like I've
never had been died and I've never
became a billionaire I was like
everything so far in life has been like
much narrower in terms of like the rain
in Texas and so it's like trying to
instill thought process of like this is
what the actual risk is at hand what is
actual worst-case scenario and then
after doing something be like did I
experience the worst case scenario
because in any it's like Schrodinger's
box right you like you open up it's like
only one thing is actually gonna happen
so theoretically you could know what was
gonna happen if you keep exercising this
skill and so early on I wanted to I
wanted to do that and that's kind of
what led us to like all the pyrotechnics
and stuff was cuz we're like it's not
the worst-case scenario is not
necessarily you die not in all
situations although most people consider
we are flirting with that instead we're
trying to like narrow down like what can
we do and learn and understand these
things and it's really just a bunch of
like physics tests which it kind of
leads to what we're what we're doing now
you know we're making a we're trying to
make a virtual physics world which all
these things kind of apply to and trying
to figure out how how we can you know
what rules and the fundamental rule
isn't like only certain things actually
can happen so early on yeah we wanted to
uh we wanted to test those things and I
don't know what my mom's a second grade
teacher she's she's at a private you
know Catholic school she's very very not
not the type that would ever take risks
bandit and for whatever reason like they
just she didn't like it what we were
doing but she but she trusts at us and
and we never we never went so far that
that we you know we burned our bridge or
we know we never crossed that line where
there was like a trip to the hospital
the ambulance camera was like a moment
in time where someone could go like all
right no more of that activity right
because those are usually once when you
when you cross the line and something
sticks out that's when you get like
slapped with the you know the authority
or is like no no more explosions in the
yard right mm-hmm but uh but yeah so so
we were trying to uh we're trying to
like figure out what the range of what
we could actually do and I think that
set us up and somehow we are gifted with
with a couple parents that didn't
immediately freak out and there's a
different political and time in the
world where even the time it seemed like
it's like man the 90s are so like strict
there's so many rules and put back in
like the 70s or the sixties like it was
so much better it's like turns out the
90s are pretty sweet too because all
these things now it seems like I'm like
I don't know it seems like yeah we were
really pushing the line stuff we were on
private property for a lot of it yeah
yeah I do feel like watching you know
watching like fail videos or people like
hurt themselves the biggest difference
between them and us growing up was that
they don't iterate they go immediately
to the full stunt yep or not to pick on
Adrien here broke his collarbone diving
over that table like there wasn't a
moment where he's like cool let me just
do a warm-up dive I'm just gonna do a
diving roll onto a pad no table no
nothing let me just let me see if I can
do that without hurting myself oh that
hurt I won't do it already table or okay
that wasn't so bad I'm a little warmed
up now I can step it up a little bit
further yep yeah
alcohol inspired zero to 60 yeah most
people take these things it's like they
get psyched up for the big stunt and
Internet videos aren't helping that
right yeah and then you get people
confidence to jump to take all the
people like blowing of fireworks in
their hand and stuff it's like now you
got a smart you start small you go
bottle rockets then the roman candles
alright and then you go to those big
artillery ones like you know there's an
order of operations here you know I have
to get comfortable you know familiar
with fuse lengths and how fast they burn
yeah how much like sparks shoot out and
like how hot that is you know it's like
and there is variance there right like
sometimes they burn faster and sometimes
they burn slower it's not a hundred
percent consistent like knowing that
you're like this could blow up the
moment like the flame touches it and and
then having that risk factor like okay
I'm not going to do that that one even
if I guess I was 2% it's 2% too much
that I might lose my hand you know they
don't see what I'm throwing a bottle
rocket is it I'm checking the the how
much paper overlap there is oh yeah you
don't like there's only as a
quarter-inch and sometimes there's none
you know yeah so it's like you need to
know when you're timing your throw yeah
that doesn't make the video they're a
big part of what we were doing we were
young like whenever you know when I'd go
to your place or Sam and I would go to
your place even be messing with stuff
like a lot of that was we're trying to
figure out how they did this the magic
of special effects in movies yeah yeah
idolizing action movies yeah it's like
bullet hits and explosions and
pyrotechnics and even you know even
stuff that wasn't like a fire base but
still extent based like remember when I
discovered that crash pads were just
cardboard boxes I mean there was like
you know there's like the smaller crash
pad there's airbags but for the most
part it's just cardboard boxes and it's
like wait I can get cardboard boxes you
know calling up a Walmart Dec hey can I
have some of your boxes and like like uh
yeah I guess just come on over like hi
I'm the fifteen-year-old kid that asks
for all your cop work boxes yeah here's
the deer's the compressor go ahead and
take whatever you want you know and then
setting them up and then not immediately
jumping off the roof onto the cardboard
boxes you know but setting them up
taking a couple steps at the ladder
falling from five feet above the boxes
okay that wasn't so bad let's take it up
to eight feet that wasn't so bad
let's take up to 10 feet okay now
starting to get a little sticky you
don't just immediately go from zero to
100 you yeah yeah I was watching the
Jake Paul Shane Dawson documentary
series mmm and in that they were doing
they were doing a big stack cardboard
boxes they're jumping into and there's
like one cutaway moment where they're
they're tying a piece of twine around
the copper boxes and chains like oh I
dunno they're like all you got to do
that to make it hold together so you
don't just go through the crack and I
was like at that moment like Jake Paul
had the exact same childhood that I did
separate I had better role models
support system but as like as
interesting seems like that's not common
knowledge the same tricks you know yeah
it's funny so obviously that that whole
process I mean I know for myself and for
Nico and then for you that that is what
primed us to become successful on
YouTube as well because you know we're
so focused on short short form content
spectacle like it's like what we liked I
think worked really well
especially in the early days of YouTube
where it's like you have people unsure
what to upload and then you have people
like yourself where you're like okay
action spectacle like we can do this for
for nothing because we've been doing it
for nothing for years now we're just
learning how to film it better yep and
how do you think like what experience is
there like like do you think it helped
you I guess become successful on YouTube
like I guess having anything from like
was it was it I don't know like or I
don't even know where this is questions
going but like I get it I got a key
thing with the the Freddy W aesthetic
yeah was that we never got we were never
I never felt like we were rewarded for
becoming for crossing a line a certain
line of like professionalism in certain
aspects like never once did I get
rewarded for addressing Freddy up in a
costume or getting like makeup done or
something like that like almost every
video concept it's like we did get
rewarded for for visual effects or a
stunt or some twist or you know a funny
idea but what we didn't but doing that a
t-shirt and jeans was almost always
better received than doing and I get a
master chief costume or something like
that okay so something we that I always
try to keep it like push away from is
not trying to build this up towards
making making like Hollywood style say
max is that this is its own medium its
own format yeah and what's working on
YouTube is trying to make keep it
accessible to the audience in it like
this is still just like some guys that
could be your friends you know this is
like it still have this vibe like
everyone knew that guy in high school or
knew that group or had someone you know
it was like that was kind of like
flirtin with the you know messing around
doing it it's like this is just this
that executed on the highest level but
it's not trying to turn the corner to
suddenly like oh this is an audition
piece for for Hollywood I'm hoping to
get noticed and make a and make them
make the next big movie or TV show yeah
he's my pilot for my comedy short series
or whatever yeah yeah very adamant that
I'm like I'm not I don't want to build
that channel to try to leverage towards
Hollywood and that's not the future that
I want to go towards because I think
that is kind of destructive towards what
that is mmm that makes sense II I mean I
feel like that's then that's something I
always am asking myself even to the
state which is like
you know like obviously we've had bigger
aspirations to try and like I I guess
jump ship it's the easiest way to say
you know into like bigger projects or
longer form content but in a way it's
like yeah this is it is its own medium
it didn't in its its own I guess
skill you know we have a profession
having done some of those bigger
projects I've realized at least how how
great the YouTube ecosystem is at least
for what I want to do yeah and I think
it a little bit for what we all want to
do you know it's working
even if you're a director on a
multi-million dollar film like you are
not in charge yep and it's not that fun
the moment that I was done with the the
Freddy W channel was the moment that we
had trailers for the actors on the set
of eg HS mmm I saw I walked in the
trailers to go get the actors and I
looked around I'm like this isn't this
isn't me anymore this isn't this isn't
what I'm aspiring to this is not what I
want to make and it's not that I don't
think that that can be good it's just a
completely different Avenue for that
that's that's like a fundamental fork
you know in what we're trying to create
and that's like on it's on a creative
side and then on the on the on the
business side that coincided with
YouTube's switch over to per minute
right which you kind of touched on
earlier it's like per minute versus perf
you know if you're financially rewarding
something per per minute it ultimately
we've seen it took years to sort of
manifest itself always seen how that's
like dictated the content on the
platform of YouTube you know
everything's trying to be longer how can
we serve up more ads and ads comes up
every about every 7 minutes and so how
do you use your retention etc whereas
before it was just like it doesn't
matter what the length of it is we're
just trying to get them in there and
then for me games is still not a per
hour thing unless you go into the the
multiplayer you know like yeah a
subscription model but on the on the
single-player side of the narrative side
which is why you like bone works is
still gonna be a narrative game it's a
you're you're ultimately you're paying
some dollars and you get a game and
you're gonna play that game and I hope
everyone that plays it is like that was
worth $1 I'll do that again so I guess
just gonna rewind a little because I you
mentioned so seeing trailers on the set
of eg HS was definitely seen it seems
like one of the defining moments
um of like when you were making that
decision to part ways but I was
wondering did you know I guess before
then a pre B GHS like as you're working
on the channel what were you feeling
that like you were ready and we move on
or what was that like um and that's it
that's how it's an interesting time to
go back to is the I mean it's definitely
like over the over a year-long decision
right it's like this is kind of like you
know things are things are changing in a
platform we started to get to the point
where it's like you know we it's like do
I want to try to push this because a lot
of youtubers don't talk about it it's
like they the youtuber burnout is often
it's like the thing that fuels them is
that is that rise that like that riding
the way of the getting up on the
surfboard right you like you're trying
to get like trying to make it grow and
inevitably at certain point that sort of
plateaus off and it's like either we're
going to keep pushing this to be number
one on YouTube you know from number five
or whatever or or leverage it into
something else you know and to keep
going but it's like in a way what keeps
you pulling the all-nighters what keeps
you up and keeps you drive is that is
that sort of momentum and I think you
see a lot of youtubers turn that corner
and they attributed this to like broad
leus burnout mm-hmm but really it's once
they aren't the hottest newest thing
anymore it's like they kind of have to
get into this like holding pattern where
it's like alright now we just need to
like maintain the audience and those
like obviously like Smosh did a very
good job and it was it was a business
that was sort of controlling all of that
that kind of kept them on a schedule you
know but as far as being like a
perennial thing that just kept going but
uh accepting this role of like just like
kind of continue to churn things out and
you have to ask yourself these at that
moment of turning it's like do I try to
reinvent what this thing is and and let
it take that you know let this ride keep
going do I change what I'm doing and and
try to go after again am i do I want in
my life where I know this transition of
like am I ready to kind of get to a more
nine-to-five and like get into that
holding pattern and maybe you know be
more interested in having and having
kids or you know getting married
something like that like let that be my
new project you know mm-hmm because I
think all of us share that right we have
a we have to have a project or you get
this like this thing that drives you and
it's like in my head I wasn't I wasn't
ready for that transition and it's like
and Freddie's reaction to it was very
much like he wanted to do vGHS and
Netflix series and tried to like go that
way cuz he was
I mean rent bracket USC he was more he
was the film student that was the more
traditional film student I was partially
in the film program but then I also did
sociology I was kind of more of a wild
card in that that I wasn't I never
really liked Hollywood I didn't like
coming out to LA I didn't really like
what I saw and I kind of like the way we
did it and Minnesota better mm-hmm and
so I always kind of had like I kind of
wanted to throw the finger to the man a
little bit more you know like I don't
want to join you I don't want to I don't
want to like sort of put you know
reinvent what you're doing it's like I
kind of want to like topple it a little
bit you know so I was spending that that
time kind of figuring out like so I got
we went forward with vGHS and doing that
and that was the first season of it was
still was still very um there was there
were some elements of both sides of it
you know and so there was some joy to be
found in there and like working with
some of the power technics and doing
some like that but then by the time that
kind of wrapped up it was like the
full-on switch was in like what's go to
let's incorporate let's make this a
thing what staff up let's try to get
away from the all-nighters and try to
regulate the schedule a little bit more
and so that kind of left me left me
searching so I still doing some videos
then I was working with working with
Kevin who was still over here doing a
game developer with us today mm-hmm and
we were doing like so these higher end
like more more visual effects heavy I
was getting more and more into the
computer work side of things like I was
finding myself enjoying the computer
work more than the sort of onset work
and then without so Freddy was always
the one that would would push me to more
get something out the door like like hey
we're shooting it today
let's just go that you know and I and I
fell into the trap more where it's like
like I'll just I'll take another week on
this one you know so start be like kind
of going these ideas so it's like the in
developing these videos and then
ultimately like after sort of like a
year that is like you know it's probably
time to split ways with this and I kind
of started looking into what's next and
I had a sort of a probably a six month
period there where I was coming to work
around like you know like 2:00 in the
afternoon or something like that like I
was kind of like looks like I was I was
resting a little bit you know and then
uh
and then it ended up being the trip up
to the valve that I mentioned earlier
where they showed us the hardware we're
like this goes into a box we're gonna
make VR content you know and I started
looking in became stuff and it's like
I'm enjoying the computer side of things
more and it suddenly got this new like
creative charge to to do that and so
sort of channeled that that Wild West
energy of like wanted to make something
new into that side of things that's
super cool yeah you tried streaming for
a little bit in there in the middle of
all that yeah that was um that was
another that's I was early like we had
the game to almost do the idea was like
let's try to develop some games like
that play off of the streaming platform
and build like the streaming platform
and try to make it like sort of an
interactive thing with that and then
largely largely streaming I found to be
really lonely which is a weird statement
and I don't think it's talked about
enough because everyone's like well how
could it be lonely you have thousands of
people watching you know as they're
doing it but it's like it's a very maybe
maybe there needs to be a new word added
to the language it's like it's not
you're not alone but it's like you
couldn't be farther yeah you're right
there's probably a German thing for that
right it's like yeah it's like okay like
make up a German word for it like yes
nothing good totally right though cuz
it's something that's very unique to
like the last five or six years here yes
I mean even it applies even I I guess
I'm YouTube you know you have people
with audiences that are in the millions
and yet they've never met a single one
of them and there's no connection yeah
or when they do they're such a divide
it's not like it's not like oh I'm with
my people now it's I'm this entity and
you're all this other entity and you're
all looking in and I'm kind of like
looking out into this void of like you
know and it's Anzio you try to make
these personal connections yeah but yet
the the way the relation just been
formed is not that's not a healthy
foundation for any relationship to like
transition to real life I don't think
you know you meet somebody that's been
spent a hundred hours already watching
you so they'd already know about your
your life and your family and everything
about you and you don't know anything
about them and now you're trying to like
how do you well it's the loneliness of
you being the only one on a stage well
performing in a glass box of the flight
one-way mirrors or two-way mirrors you
know it's like you have no idea what the
reaction is but like trust me there's
millions of people out there yeah staged
loneliness that's my word for it staged
loneliness yeah that's that's probably
it's probably a well documented thing
actually yeah you see I mean you
definitely see signs of all the
youtubers and and twitch stars like they
suffer from it right I think I mean
though and I think the ones that can
really succeed are the people who are
able to like overcome overcome that in
like over I guess I guess it's it's it's
it's the idea of imagining that these
that like sorry I guess imagining is the
word the people are actually watching
there are that these are real people but
being able to like get over that mental
hurdle of just because you can't see him
or can't hear him or whatever it's like
really embracing that and like really
understanding that and using that to
fuel your performance in a way I guess
that's one way of putting it it reminds
me of when saying when you and I went up
to this is actually a note integration
but saying our the once you drew the
stars for this one oh we went up to
Ubisoft in San Francisco to play I think
was far cry 4 okay yeah I remember that
there's co-op so I was like the perfect
Sam and I will go up and we'll co-op it
yeah and we record some footage of that
and there's our note video and we go up
and we sit in a room and there's all
these other streaming personalities I
didn't really know any of them youtubers
streamers ever ever everything yeah and
so they were all alone they're all by
themselves
Sam when I were the only people who went
up as a team to play co-op together
everybody else is playing by themselves
okay it was the same when I sit down to
start playing and like like regular
friends you just started having fun
together and you start talking and like
that's it you know you're just playing
the game together yeah it's it's
completely normal but all these are the
guys they sit down I start playing
suddenly they all start getting really
loud and they're talking but they're not
talking to anyone they're by themselves
each one of them is by themselves I'll
be talking to themselves it was really
really weird
they're like erupting into laughter and
then making goofy voice isn't talking
about the animals and stuff and it's
just like whoa like you guys actually do
that live like you
just record the footage and then just
like no home I mean some I mean I feel
like the more proper method is record it
quietly and then you go home and then
you just rip over a microphone over the
footage yeah and it feels like they feel
that that sequence in Barako it like
that the chickens like all the bunch of
crazy people for a moment there because
like you're in an insane asylum sitting
by himself like a video game like when I
play video games
I shot up silent for two hours yeah the
relative weirdness would be like imagine
imagine like Jimmy Kimmel just like in
his house by himself doing the Jimmy
Kimmel show or like the announces of a
football game like Bob Costas but the
Olympics is just like just do the
Olympic like myself over here just like
watching a football game and like
announcing while they're by themselves
like sitting on the couch yeah this is
like over be imagine you have to be like
I'm a new football announcer right I'm
just gonna put a camera myself I'm
announcing the game that's funny no
one's tried that yet ready could do it I
mean I'm sure I'm sure that you found no
way it's just like yeah a live football
commentary by just anyone like yeah yeah
that's crazy it's super crazy well
here's here's just one thought I was
thinking about a little bit here and
maybe there's not a actual answer to it
but early on our conversation we were
talking about steam and how it kind of
has shaped the gaming industry you know
in a similar way to how YouTube has
shaped I guess filmmaking in the video
um especially when we see like early
access titles and how it's made it so
more people can produce it now on
YouTube though we've kind of started to
see you know I guess that's been curbed
lately through how would they want to
optimize it through I'm sorry how they
want to optimize it you know through
through watch time and how like bigger
companies are finally starting to buy
into it and things like that what do you
think would hurt the gaming industry I
guess in in that similar sense you know
like is is
I guess with you-know-who how could you
spoil what's good about the state of PC
gaming right now these be entirely a
switch over to uh developers being paid
per hour of playtime mmm pretty much if
they that thing that something that's
been obviously tossed around by a lot of
competitors and a lot of different
companies it's like as a model right if
they switched over to you pay you get
the twenty bucks a month you know
subscription to you know the Netflix
model of a theme or something like that
right and then the revenue is
distributed based on per hour of play
time what you play yes psychological
manipulation environment yes of playing
games well I mean modify model how much
different is that from just like thrown
in quarters into an arcade machine
though in a sense very similar to to it
to an arcade machine I think the
difficulty is you'd see similarly to an
arcade like how the content is developed
right it's like you're now it's a
completely different parameter instead
of parameters that you're developing for
where you're thinking of how do I
maximize how many quarters they put in
so I better either kill the player here
on this boss or something like that it's
not it's not as much about how much it's
fun it's how many cores does it take to
beat this game it's I got to get them
far enough in the first quarter to get
them hooked and make them think that
they just need one more quarter and then
tease them with the ending so it's like
oh we're so far just like just another
quarter just another quarter right and
to try to get in there and that's that's
that's a slightly different model
because presumably your players have an
unlimited number of quarters or whatever
or they can you know they can somehow
produce more quarters right because
you're looking at a relatively small
amount of money that I mean I'm sure for
a lot of kids like they have they've got
a stack and when they're out they're
gonna leave but uh but most you know
they can come back once their allowance
they're in place more right but if it's
per month and it's per like a set amount
of time like the Netflix model then
suddenly the way you're creating your
content is entirely based on watch time
or play time it just some things would
come out of it that argued be better but
other things would come out of it that
are significantly worse in it like a lot
of large genre of games that I point you
like like inside or something like that
like a shorter game that's probably like
a little more premium four dollars so
like you know like eight bucks per per
hour of gameplay or so completely dies
out over the course of
five years like that ceases to exist
yeah and then in terms of games like
dayz or a or pub G or something that's
something that's gonna put lots and lots
of hours of gameplay for you know for
for the amount of dollars you pay for it
that's the type of thing that's gonna
get the lion's share of the revenue so
is that better is that worse I don't
know it's definitely different it just
like YouTube it would change the content
that's out and so I think you could I
just I'd encourage any of the platforms
to think long and hard about why are
they what how they want to sculpt the
content in what packages they want do
and how that no matter what they do
there the way the financial incentives
ation works forms the creative and the
rate of will match the financial model
because ultimately it cost money to
develop these things yeah and they're
gonna have to adapt to that right that
makes sense that's basically what you're
seeing with more or less amounts to
gambling right now and free-to-play
games yep you know the creative falls
into trying to encourage you to well
it's just that so it's hooking you in
and giving those little like bits of
success and starting to tie that to all
you'll get more that success if you
start spending a little bit of money
yeah yeah something I've been playing
around with so right now the way that
reviews work on on Steam are it's it's
everything goes right like all the
reviews go in and you're seeing over the
last couple years a lot more negatively
reviewed games right because the
community is largely realized that the
best way to get the attention of a
developer is to leave a negative review
and then when they address that issue
maybe you switch it to positive or maybe
you don't but essentially that's your
forum
now I'm gonna post there and not nearly
it's not really I don't think is really
affecting the bottom line I think it's
affecting the psychology of a lot of
like the the psychological state of a
lot of the developers tantrum tactic
yeah because they take it very
personally when they see all those
negative views you know they see the red
and they want to make the red go away
it's working you know like you're
getting your attention but this is other
like the community hub which they don't
you know it's just supposed to be the
venue for that that people don't want to
use because the review bombing is the
more direct tactic and then you have the
issue of like of users that I find
myself in the category of something I've
always liked about gaming is I imagine
that there's gonna be this emergence of
the equivalent of like a Western in film
where you have like these like kind of
like
older dudes are like these genres of
like these older dudes are injured like
first man was a movie with Ryan Gosling
that came out like that's an older dude
movie right that's like like 35 40 year
olds are gonna go and get a beer that
movie
is it going to moon escape or
responsibilities on earth when I go the
moon I bring hope anything no I'm not
but now just you me but to all America
you're crazy boys want to just drink
brewskis on the moon really like this is
like or you know any Western type of
thing like that I want that to immersion
gaming where like if you figured like
there's all these guys like us you know
I'm 32 now I going on 33 and like as
week sure to get older 40 like you got
like you know the Clint Eastwood films I
wanna be like a Clint eventually I want
to be like a 60 70 year old Clint
Eastwood developer it's like making
games for the retirement home it's like
you know it's like for this genre but
the problem I see is that if if all the
reviews of the games are gonna be
filtered through like the latest
generation of 12 year olds and 14 year
old it's like that's not very good
information for the older ageing gamer
who kind of comes in I think I think
we're all learning to like - now the
review system because it's like I always
look at a game and I see like okay this
is that 70% positive I do a quick
analysis I'm like I bet most of the
negative reviews are because like not
worth $20 for the shortlink then I
scroll down and I see a bunch of them I
see yep yep yep so I felt it was out of
my like okay so this is actually
probably like a 90% for my demo because
I'm I'm of the I'm of the age where I'm
like I'm not looking for an 80-hour game
in this I'm looking to play like I want
a really good four hours of gameplay I
want to sit down over two nights play
this thing and get back to my life and
I'm okay with spending you know a movie
ticket prize you know 20 bucks or
something like that to do that and I
understand this
for everybody but I'm like how do you
make it so that there's a way within the
system - like differentiate these games
where it's like I almost wanted like the
old like Netflix model where you like
say like what are twenty games you like
or whatever relate these things and then
based on that they're like based on your
here's the overall community like
usually overall rescore but here's like
what we think you'd give it you know cuz
you have a history of really wanting a
hundred hours of content for for ten
bucks and so therefore this is the game
for you or you've got a history of like
you want you don't really even finish
the games you play you tend to put about
four hours each and you like you you
highly rated this game so therefore this
one's for you I think there's a lot of
room for like algorithmic you know like
for these like a secondary system on top
of the first one to help recommend
things like that - it makes a lot of
sense users yeah I'm surprised that I
mean Steam but not in the way you're
describing I would even just say like
yeah like I've seen the same thing with
reviews yeah it's most it's mostly like
a time to money ratio that's I think the
big thing that I've noticed on most of
the games I'm playing anyways yeah I
brought it up to some engineers there
and they like the gut reaction was like
oh you're asking for an echo chamber
it's like no that's like that's not what
I'm asking for it's like there's a
there's some ik but I could definitely
once I heard that my guys see that angle
of it it's like so maybe like both
systems need to coexist but it's like
you know not looking for an echo chamber
you're looking for like I'm just looking
for artificial intelligence to predict
what I'll think of things and choose
formula well then I want robots
overlords I would really like it if all
the companies that have like these
artificial intelligence suggestion
algorithms Spotify YouTube heck humans
team it'd be really nice to just opened
up what your inputs were to that
algorithm because sometimes I won't be
like look let me pretend that for a day
I'm really into fighting games let me
just tell you what fighting games I like
so you can tell me what fighting games I
should buy okay cool I'm not really into
fighting games you'll never suggest me a
fighting game but I kind of want to
dabble I want to try them out so let me
get share with you some new set of
inputs and see what your outputs are oh
cool here's some fighting games for me
to try great thank you okay I want to
try JRPGs now I'm not really into JRPGs
but here's the ones I do like here's a
new set of inputs please give me some
outputs like you can't do that with
Spotify I can't be like
you know I want to get back into jazz
but like here's the jazz I like yeah I
they don't give you any those parameters
and yeah you type jazz and then you said
you just get like thousands of just
randomly you play like this it's like
how much it's like this is useless it's
like I want to be I want to be Chris
Pratt today just give me Chris Pratt's
YouTube suggests that's funny actually
that's really funny the curator like
today like you wanna be think you're not
even curated dude it's just like
straight up going into their brain it's
like oh man yeah I was like yeah it's
like I think everybody went through they
all watched up what's that post that
prehistoric technology technology yeah
everybody's like gone on that binge of
primitive technology and then for like
the next month users like you wanna
watch a pottery video it's like no this
technology these guys in Vietnam copied
primitive technology maybe like that
yeah no I just want like one little bar
of him if you put a new video and then
like nothing else strike that from the
record you know yeah yeah it's really
funny all right well well to to wrap
things up I want to talk about one last
thing yeah I think you'll do it so at
the very beginning here when we're
standing in the studio and Brendan said
guys I have some ideas to talk about
there's one that we haven't gotten to
yet
oh really yeah so let's say you're
making a fast and furious movie uh-huh
and your lead actor dies in a fiery car
accident yeah what do you do well well
let's say you want to protect against
that what do you do now well though it
would emerged a few years back like a
decade ago now is as this I think was
pretty much like the Matrix sequels
where probably wouldn't really got rust
onto the public stage right was a
digital doubles right making digital
humans and the idea of being able to
scan model and clone and start to render
it was like as soon as we turned over to
have like nice skin shaders and stuff we
started thinking about like we can make
some really good CG doubles and they
could do stunts and then from from the
matrix we got like pirates the Caribbean
2 or suddenly you had Jack Sparrow's
bouncing off of like you know falling
down like a Looney Tunes character and
stuff like that and we we've gone
through the throws of it and then we get
it into the phase of what's the face
social network oh yeah the Winklevoss
twins wrinkle Watson so you got to
social network phase where suddenly
you're doing oh there's only one of
these actors there's no twins at all but
we're just doubling their face and you
never knew our Benjamin Button you know
you start having these things where like
we're passing it off as real mm-hmm and
now we're in the the final phase of it
where every single movie that costs over
a hundred million dollars in existence
is scanning mandatorily scanning every
single actor that's inside of them and
then they can use those actors for in
the event of like look at the Star Wars
movies you know like we can we can bring
young Carrie Fisher back we can bring
old Carrie Fisher back which is what's
gonna happen in Episode nine right she's
gonna be in there and she's gonna be CG
and her family's gonna get paid and
they're and they signed on that one like
let's do this you know because why not
just why not just milk that cow one more
time all right I feel like they signed
it and now but they no one's yet seen
the true repercussions of it yeah so you
have so pretty much we have a database
and you're starting to see it come to a
head I think Entertainment Weekly they
just in the last like week there was a
bunch of news stories that came out
where Digital Domain wanted to publicize
their department and you're starting to
see both sides where there's like
there's there's the hey look at this
cool technological angle thing we're
doing now and then there's also the
foreboding like who is bad and then you
have the actors Union being like we'd
like to get rid of this and you know
something obviously you can't get rid of
it once the cats out of them thank you
know like and people are gonna keep
signing and you can just put that log
line on the contractor it's like sign it
or don't sign it you're gonna be scanned
but with this comes all these stories of
actors wreck I don't want to do all the
facial expressions I don't know how
you're gonna use them you might make you
might make a sex tape of me or something
you could you know I think like and then
it goes on and on and they realize that
there's nothing that's gonna stop the
technology from photo-real humans and
the recreation of those so I was reading
about this and I took I kind of I I I've
gone back and forth on it left and right
and then it's interesting because it's
something that we do too is we're making
or making games now so the workflow that
we have right now for our game
characters is we cast somebody before we
make the model of the character and we
cast them so that we can scan them so we
have because I've been playing we
haven't executed on it yet but
I want to have the ability to do
live-action sequences with the actors
potentially and so rather than trying to
cast a look-alike and do a cosplay thing
like let's just let's just do it the
film way of let's get somebody let's do
wardrobe let's get the costume ready and
then let's scan them model it and have
it all ready and we'll have both and
then the technology also emerge in the
real-time environment to use Apple's
their their face FaceTime Cammy and
emojis they an emoji system yeah and you
can actually Pike that two characters in
the unity now and so we can use that for
the facial capture so we now have both
workflows where it's like we can do we
can take a realistic of a character as
we want as we can make and put them in
there and have them talking in game or
we could do a live-action equivalent
them and film a live action sequence etc
and theoretically these technologies
emerge to being interchangeable and then
it comes down to the wonderful state of
what's the best tool for the job it's
like do we want to do a you know what do
I film you right now to us can you right
now to want to bring you back in for
this to want us do a digital pickup and
these options are very liberating as a
creator mm-hmm but the exception is that
actors take exception to it because I
think the way they're trying to phrase
it is like is I think it's the wrong
angle right now but it's it's kind of
the obvious angle is oh you can imagine
like they're gonna bring me back when
I'm dead against my will you know I'm
not gonna like they can just keep making
movies with me and I won't be need my
consent and that's that's terrible isn't
that spooky and it's like if you're the
only value is your facial structure then
maybe yeah I kind of call [ __ ] on
that yes I don't think you're worried
about when you're dead I think your
agents telling you this cuts into your
value because who gets paid the most on
a movie right this is the attacker right
the actor especially if you know what a
list actor gets paid way more than the
guy shining the light at the actor or
the person pointing the camera and why
is that it's it's it's scarcity right
there's only one of them and inherently
with them filmmaking process you've sold
the audience on their face the value
they bring people into the theater now
they've been built up and so that's
that's where the value is so they demand
really high rates mm-hmm and they all
have writers where it's like hey if you
need to do pickups of me that's gonna be
an extra like say Robert Downey jr. or
something it's like that's another five
hundred thousand dollars for like two
days of a day or something like that
like we're
ridiculous rates right to come in and
suddenly the studio goes we just need
like a couple rice miles out of Robert
Downey jr. it's like it cost 500 grand
and we'll agree to give him 500 grand
but what it turns out is we're just
gonna tell them hey we got everything we
needed know reshoots needed but they're
going in and doing is they're getting
mall and pick up shots they need of him
and not paying him and that's really the
problem and that's that's the problem
the agents mind in its actors that's all
money that's a good thing movie honest
that's a great thing well it's it's a
screw getting paid five hundred thousand
dollars for two days of work that's a
total like mess-up of like the economic
structure of a movie if that's where
your values are going yes that's if the
animator finds it morally reprehensible
you know what they're gonna find other
another animator an actor finds it they
are the only one that has like some
weight to throw around because that's
that's their leverage so there's that's
why we're getting chiseled away that's
fixing an economic pinch bottleneck in
films that should be fixed yeah and I
know I'm like bunker and down and
getting ready for the battle cuz I'm
like the actors before you know it
they're gonna have the actors Union like
picketing out in front of studios like
no there's no humans and it's gonna be
all these people that haven't had a
chance to act yet that could be hired to
be Robert Downey jr. are gonna get that
job and they're having them go out there
and pick it so they can like try to win
favor with the actors Union well and
they're gonna manipulate them I think
this together you gotta I think get down
on a deeper level with this though
because I I understand your point Niko
about I guess the inflation of like the
economics of entertainment you know
through this you know for celebrity
millions and millions of dollars kind of
sets a standard in a way and then it all
trickles down from there it's basically
a monopoly on a small scale it is but
like let's work on I think it's about we
need to get to why you think that
because I think along the way I mean I
think there's some things we're not
considering here um so like what is the
value of a celebrity you know what
ultimately is it is it their face you
know it's not just should be the
performance well it's it's it's it's
unfortunately not just the performance
it it's a combination I would save you
know three things you have their face
yeah slash their physical form you have
the second of which which is there
I guess performance slash their
decision-making process because that is
you generally unique to a performer you
know how how creative are you how how
can you how can you work emotions and
you know manipulate an audience
etc etc so there's the actual craft of
the profession and then I would argue
there's probably the last thing which is
the way they are able to control their
public appearance like outside of a
performance you know you look at Chris
Evans going to a hospital or like how
these charity things or like oh they're
cool or they're featured here there and
so it's this concept of they are also
actually a really cool human being you
know they're a nice person which then
makes it so when you see them in a movie
or like that guy so cool also he's
really good at what he does you know
basically Captain America in real life
yeah so he is Captain America so you
have to like consider that let's say an
actor is doing all of these things as
hard as best as they can they're
maintaining their physical form they're
honing in on their craft and they are
trying to be a really great person in
real life you know and so that's how
they create their value is by just doing
all of this and now you physically scan
them you put them on a like a you know
you make a stamp out of them to put them
wherever you want um you know you kind
of I guess it does it does go against
like the value that that actor did
create mm-hmm yeah well what I see is
you know filmmaking is an artistic
process too at the end of the day and
every should bring value to the thing
that they are truly valuable and an
actor is valuable for their performance
first and foremost yes there's that
public persona but to me that's really
not entirely relevant to what their job
is just like Roger Deakins like he's a
great cinematographer and his movies
look beautiful yeah that's what matters
you know it doesn't matter that he's got
a good public facing brand you know so I
mean I ideally do not like an [ __ ]
that matters I have a hard time
you know it consuming art from [ __ ]
but you know for an actor to me what's
most important is their performance and
when like you were mentioning branding
like when pickups cost I'm half million
dollars a day or you know in Bruce
Willis's case probably a million dollars
a day cuz it but no Bruce Willis is just
straight up a million dollars a day yeah
that's not there's no performance in
like oh I need a shot of you like
turning to the right because we've
filmed it on the wrong side when we on
the day or like you know clouds over the
Sun or some like that that's just like
completely artificial inflation of the
budget so you can milk another half a
million dollars out of the studio and
that's when you get really weird
economics and film and that's when you
get barriers of entry to all the other
filmmakers trying to get into it so to
me something like this is opening up
that creative pathway and letting the
filmmakers make a better movie which at
the end of the day is better for the
people consuming the movie yeah and the
actor is still getting paid but they're
getting paid for what their actual value
is which is the craft of acting also
there's an opportunity cost right it's
like you can only make so many movies a
year because you only have so much time
but suddenly if it's like oh we only
need you like real you for two months
and then digital you for the rest then
suddenly there's more things we've done
so there's there's less scarcity of that
resource
I mean maybe like you commented you met
the you met the rock and you come at it
like how does he do so many things a day
what if it comes out that half the time
it's just digital he's hiding like he's
guy he's like I've been like half the
shots you see of me are seized by his
head is shaved and that's white see he's
he's already easier to render t CG I
have to preface this and say like I have
nothing there's a there's probably it's
just a few bad actors that are that that
are that are spoiling it for the bunch
and most of them are probably very pure
and true yeah but the insurance policy
is often because there's a high rate of
like overdose and drug abuse and getting
out of shape that happens right after
films it's like a spike like there's
there's a height like if you looked if
you looked at the data analysis of all
actors for the last 50 years post big
movie like that's when they go to rehab
right
and why is that is it they'd like to say
is it the stresses of the job is it oh
it's like it's like this this role was
so emotionally taxing I don't think so
I think you just cash a big check a huge
block of free time and you're just going
hard partying yeah for a few months and
then they end up od'd and now it's like
now we can't even get you further
reshoots and you're out of shape like
like Ben Affleck after after a Superman
or no Batman the Batman vs. Superman
movie they end up doing CG him for
reshoots because he got so like bloated
in and out of shape he didn't he didn't
maintain his physique you know after why
would he write and it's like and maybe
there was a little bit like he didn't to
make that movie he just wanted to check
right he's like I was gonna power
through this garbage movie so that I can
get this check and what'd he do
afterwards he partied I hit it hard and
so they didn't use him for reaches they
see cheat him because he's done sells
like insurance policy pays off it's like
you got what you wanted lotta zeros in
the bank accounts off we go see one he
wanted to direct the next one yeah I'm
not I'm not arguing against it I think
it's super valuable and I think everyone
should should do it but I think it's the
question of like its it's trying to do
is do with do that as like you did
completely in lieu of something that you
should be probably roping the actor into
but at this point the thing is anytime
you're doing that for a movie your
budget is so high that half of it half
of the movies in animation at that point
and having real actors is kind of
irrelevant anyways at that point yeah
like it almost in a CG almost blends
better with the CG backgrounds anyways
might as well just put a couple more
strings on that face of yours yeah I got
very one-sided because I'm kind of like
anticipating like a frustrating like
like campaign leveraged by the actors
eden's to try to like get public opinion
behind them cuz even actually they're
influencers so I'll try to be like no we
can't do this I know I honestly it's a
bunch of just grumpy people and agents
probably because it is it is the
additional money from reshoots but
ultimately like you you the quite the
thing the way you stomp on that is just
to say alright in this scene we want you
to fly you know it's like can you do
that it's like we need to scan you man
yeah there's also some fear to think if
you feel like like I am probably getting
paid a little disproportionately for
what I'm contributing to this project
I'm gonna be defensive of that position
right like if you really are like you're
worth every penny you're making you're
not gonna worry about like it's just
best tool for the job like let's make
some let's make art here with you yeah
cool I think ultimately that's the
mindset that it's you know that people
have to remind themselves of yeah that's
that's really what you're doing yeah
like I hope that I think it's a more
comfortable position like you're gonna
sleep better at night if you're never
trying to get paid more than you're
worth right like you're just trying to
like I just want to work hard I want to
use my talents and and hard work and
energy to get paid what I'm what I'm
worth then it's like that's that's a
position that you can like hang your
head on like you'll always have a place
in this world if you can bring your
table yeah I mean and then that's how
the industry actually really works at
its core it's people who are easy to
work with and who enjoy being paid
fairly and etc etc it's like those are
the relationships that last I think that
goes for everything you know it's about
being honest and having respect for
colleagues and having respect for the
work that you're doing yeah but the
system already filters out like the
truly bad eggs like if someone's a real
pain to work with and you hear some of
these stories and I was it's like if
they're if it's really that bad their
careers probably gonna the window and go
away so it's like this it's probably
being embellished a bit if they tend to
like stick around for 20-year long
careers like someone was like I'm right
like it has be the ownerle challenge I
really see is that like the one thing
that the digital scanning does it does
when I mentioned the puppet thing
earlier I say that because any like big
movie like a Star Wars film I mean
really any Disney movie at this point a
Marvel film a Star Wars film whatever
like they ought you are basically a
puppet like the earlier is saying the
cameras gonna make this move over this
amount of time there's your one mark
there's your other mark you need to say
these lines at this cadence while
walking at this speed and at this point
you will smile and look over there yep
you do not make any decisions they've
always made for you yeah well they've
been made like the decisions are made by
the previous artists who uh read the
script and then made an animation of the
whole movie before you even got to
yes like a terminator right it's like I
want you to come in and say I'll be back
right here just lucky didn't the first
ones like not just like it like exactly
like thanks so much so that like we're
not gonna have you do it we got it we
twitch that you made you know the one
thing we're leaving out of this entire
conversation is voice voice is actually
such an important part of performance
that you can't quite replicate as easily
as everything else not yet very close
yeah do you think we're on the edge
maybe it's just we haven't put as much
energy towards synthesizing voices I
feel like audio is always like kind of
neglected compared to visual right we
put emphasis there yeah it seems like if
we put the same energy towards audio
that we did towards video audio be
leagues beyond where like if humans this
appreciated what her ears did rather
than appreciating what her eyes did more
audios like adios I think on a
fundamental level easier to manipulate
and create then light yeah I don't know
and compared to like video right now
like when you look at like an
uncompressed 16-bit audio channel versus
a 4k d NX HR video file like you're
literally using like like a thousandth
of the data in your audio stream and so
basically that means you can apply a
thousand times more processing power to
manipulating audio you know so and just
yeah you're right you're totally right
but I try to I've heard some stuff and
they're closed they're very close super
close but it's still a little robotic
and janky but yeah really close I mean
that's to me I think that's the one
thing that people really underestimate
when it comes to performances I think
you can you can kind of get by looking
anyway you look as long as you look a
little unique in Hollywood I really
don't think looks are as big of a deal
as people make him out to be like you're
not gonna be the dashing handsome lead
but you couldn't fulfil almost any other
role as long as you can kind of play
into your archetype you know yeah but to
me like obviously performance is key but
like I think what makes a performance
more almost than anything else is your
voice yeah and I think that goes to show
like wouldn't you have something like
the lego movie and they cast all these
like like Chris Pratt you think Chris
Pratt wouldn't put Chris Pratt you think
Chris Pratt would only be cast if you
could see him but he's a good voice
actor analyze actors do you think are
only popular because they look good no
it's because they actually they have
really good voice acting so
a lot of emotion and inflection comes
through in the vocal decisions you make
when you're performing so yeah watch out
when they start doing audio scans like
alright make all the the phonemes or
whatever they are yeah
mandatory vocal scanning is where people
are really gonna throw but that's what
I'm talking about earlier it's it is
those decisions and so it's like when
you come to that point where you're
recreating people you know it's it's not
so much about the fact that it's a you
you get less money but it's the fact
that I am then taking your image and I'm
putting it on a screen and I'm saying
that's Nico and you're like no that that
what that's not I didn't do that like
that doesn't represent me yeah and I
think it's I think that's I think the
true fundamentals in active duty not to
just portray another character
completely and wholly and eliminate
themselves from the process I don't
quite get it
is it important to that when Keanu
Reeves is playing neo that it is neo and
not Keanu Reeves who's gonna play neo
then you cast like the a-lister and
you're in your animated movie just so
when it comes time for PR that on Jimmy
Kimmel you can be like we got Chris
Pratt here for the animated movie it's
like I don't know like are they the best
are they the best voice actor they're
good you know not bad they get the job
done but objectively the best yeah yeah
I think we're after and on that note
actually okay starting at early day well
yeah doodle dooing
one of the rooster do a little doom is
that good technical term for this app
yes it is
okay wired I can always come back
whatever you guys say I'm just as much
confidence as you could make it seem
true thanks for having me guys yes
thanks for joining us in the podcast
brain and that was a good conversation
absolutely is there anything you want
the listeners to
check out that you're working on there
will be soon I think I mean we've been
getting
I've been uncharacteristically quiet for
the last like six months about what
we're doing and a lot of that is this
because we've been so heads down working
on it like I assure you guys that we've
been we've been plugging away everyday
Nico and Sam have seen it like just
pulling her hair off trying to get
everything together and we got we
probably to a fault we haven't shown
anything we're doing but the plan is
definitely to open up a lot more and and
start showing what we're what we're
doing what we're working on we'll be
releasing in 2019 bone works will be
coming out in 2019 and we'll have we'll
get it we'll get this team this will get
a steam page up soon and start talking
about it start showing things and start
being open because yeah a fundamental
core of like what we did with the Freddy
W channel was to talk more behind the
scenes and show what we're doing and we
intend to do this with this progress
process - to a fault like we want to
I've never gotten burned by it yet where
it's like I wish I didn't tell people
how to do that because now everyone's
doing it better than me no idea and they
ran with it now they're ahead of us it's
like if you're scared of that then it's
like you got no got no business trying
to even do something new like share it
and work on the next thing right can you
share with us who you're speaking of
digital actors key share with us here
digital actors are for the lead it's
gonna be Brett Brett the son Brett the
son yeah we're like we got up and he's
we're like we we fell in love with the
idea of a southern of having of having
that accent but not having him be like
when he's not done great oh my god like
if I ever had an accident in anything
it's like it's never gonna be a
unintelligent character because that's
just that's just not fun right Bret is
right as an intelligent character with
full southern accent and uh and yeah
there'll be will be multiple Bret's in
the oh really yeah Wow in some ways both
be the enemy and the the main character
so Wow it'll be some bread on brass
mysterious his bone works just a game
about like doing bone surgery no it's
[Laughter]
also real soon all right a skeleton
themed game
[Laughter]
yeah sweet elephant's well I come back
if there's if the comments are flood
with questions I know they wanted to
hear about Freddie Duffy's stuff we
touched on that a little bit we can't
get more into it later we get more into
the back whatever it's all good sign the
wall again right there yeah all right
Brennan thanks for joining us on the
podcast absolutely thanks everybody for
listening to the corridor casts it was
great having Brandon watch on and if you
enjoyed that podcast don't forget to
subscribe
wherever you like to listen to your
podcasts and if you want to do a little
bit more if you're feeling really really
into it today head on over to court or
digital dot store and get yourself some
merchandise we got merchandise all over
the place and honestly I think that's
the best way to support this podcast it
is free and always will be
so snag a cool t-shirt for yourself and
represent peace